Vsauce Kevin here now let's paint a
classic rainbow green good yellow nice
red spectacular and we're done because
for most of human history there was no
blue I mean of course blue existed
ancient humans had the same biological
visual systems for observing colors we
have today and clothing dyed blue with
indigo has existed from the Indus Valley
Harappan to the Han Dynasty in China but
take a look at these old paintings and
you'll see there's no blue
so did rainbows themselves change no you
can even see blue sky and blue water in
these paintings which means blue paint
existed but the rainbow of colors is
missing blue they observed blue and used
blue but didn't see blue as part of the
rainbow why because blue is clearly an
important color it's everywhere except
it's not when it comes to blue foods you
have blueberries which are actually a
deep purple plants have no true blue
pigment the less than 10% of flowers
that look blue ish are like that due to
the natural modification of a red
pigment called anthocyanin the same
thing in blueberries and cherries
well what about blue animals blue birds
a mandrels blue nose and but the blue
footed boobie your Uncle Louie may have
a pet parrot with bright blue feathers
but blue animals haven't been and
continue not to be a very common part of
our lives in terms of blue minerals the
Egyptians imported the rare blue stone
lapis lazuli from thousands of miles
away 6000 years ago
the legendary talisman of Sharla
king of the franks purportedly contained
a fragment of the cross upon which Jesus
Christ was crucified set between two
blue sapphire gems the most valuable
object the most powerful Christian King
was encased in blue while in the east
the blue Buddha carved from lapis lazuli
represented healing wisdom and
compassion
so basically when we finally found
something blue it was like this seems
important like my eyeballs blue eyes
have only existed for about seven
thousand years and were traced to a
common ancestor in Spain today people
with blue eyes only represent about 8%
of the population so on this blue marble
called earth there's not really much
blue anywhere except the entire sky
I think classical Arabic and Persian
poetry frequently refer to the sky as
the green and up until about the 13th
century the sky was primarily considered
white because of its association with
light during day time and yeah the sky
and water are often blue but not always
on overcast days the sky can be white or
gray and at night it's black water can
look gray green or have no color at all
water was often green on maps and wasn't
established as blue until the 17th
century green and blue are separated by
only 35 nanometers on the visible light
spectrum making them even closer than
violet and indigo
the thing is in languages ranging from
old Irish to Japanese green and blue
were just one word
it's tough to imagine lumping together
blue and green but you probably lumped
together dull boy and Seanie in Russia
light blue and dark blue are known as
gullible and Seanie respectively and a
2006 study found that Russian speakers
were faster at discriminating to
separate colors when shown blues that
fell into their linguistic category
English speakers who really only have
one word for blue showed no advantage
when you don't have different words to
distinguish shades blue is just blue
it's really hard to categorize a
difference quickly but not only were
green and blue once one color for a
while there were actually only three
colors black white and red were the
first recognized colors in virtually
every civilization here's why black and
white come from dark and light red comes
from poisonous fruits and from blood
spilled during hunting battle or injury
and also represents the fertility
associated with menstruation the deeply
rooted impact of the black white red 3
color system can be seen in Snow White a
story that has existed cross-culturally
in multiple forms for hundreds of years
Snow White has lips as red as blood and
hair as black as ebony wood and when her
evil stepmother tries to poison her with
a red apple she tries to convince Snow
White it's not poisoned so she eats the
apple with her but the stepmother eats
the white part which is not poisoned and
makes Snow White eat the red part which
is poisoned the colors are important is
what I'm trying to say humans have
always observed other colors but we just
compartmentalized them into black white
and red yellow was associated with white
and green blue and violet were linked
with black eventually yellow and green
became unique colors in their own right
there's plenty of both in nature but
still no one was talking about blue
early languages like Greek Hebrew and
Chinese had no specific word for blue
the words they use to represent colors
weren't necessarily describing an exact
hue but instead could reflect brightness
or even quality so a better translation
for green might be pale and white might
be shining you hear that dr. Resnick
I'm not vitamin D deficient I'm shining
hey how about you give us a specific
example of blue missing from the past
okay
a famous 1858 study by William Gladstone
showed that Homer's The Odyssey mentions
black 200 times wipe around 100 red less
than 15 yellow and green under 10 and
blue a whopping zero times the Greeks
did have a word glucose that could mean
light blue but glucose was more about
describing the feeling of a color and
could also mean gray yellow or brown and
the Hebrew tekhelet described a colorant
which came from a mollusk that could be
used to dye garments blue or violet when
we did develop words for blue they were
rooted in materials rather than the
abstract concept of color the Egyptians
had a word for their blue pigment ezio
the first synthetic pigment ever created
but after the fall of Rome the
complicated process of making egyptian
blue was lost along with the romans word
for it hyrulean
since the Latin lexicon had a gap for
blue the most common modern words for
blue derived from German and Arabic both
of whom made and traded blue in the 13th
century woad began being produced on a
large scale for dyeing clothes making
blue from yellow flowers for the masses
influenced the cultures need for a word
to describe that color that word was
blue the word asier comes from the
Arabic lash word which was used to
describe cobalt oxide blue glass and
ceramics as well as lapis lazuli the
deep blue metamorphic rock was mined
from a single mountain range in
Afghanistan the sar-e-sang or the valley
of this
after about three thousand years we
finally figured out how to extract just
the Magnificent blue to create a pigment
called ultramarine ultramarine was the
first truly vibrant blue pigment in the
world and was extremely rare and
expensive blue became more valuable than
gold
painters reserved it for only the most
important subjects like the Virgin
Mary's robe but only the rich blue
bloods could possibly afford
ultramarine it took an accident with red
blood to bring blue to the world a
pigment maker named Dee Spock was trying
to create a popular read out of Cochin
eel an insect still used for red dye in
everything from lipstick to ketchup
he added iron sulfate mixed with potash
which we later discovered has a useful
element now called potassium
anyway the potash he used was
contaminated with animal blood which
contains iron and rather than creating
red he accidentally invented an
affordable long lasting true blue when
it came to making red pigment he really
blew it named Prussian blue after its
use as a dye for Prussian army uniforms
its popularity went global it
reinvigorated Japanese woodblock
painting which went on to influence
manga which led to Japanese animation
and it also revolutionized architecture
in 1842 English astronomer Sir John
Herschel used Prussian blue to invent
blueprints eliminating the need for
architectural drawings to be arduously
hand copied so you can thank blue for
Dragonball Z and buildings but clothing
is where blue cemented its use in
everyday life
black gave way to blue as the colour of
choice for uniforms from sailors and
guards to police officers and postal
workers the working class became
blue-collar and the explosive popularity
of rugged denim jeans brought blue to
everyone
it's impossible to understate how
quickly our modern world exploded with
color it was only 350 years ago and Sir
Isaac Newton changed the world
when experiments with prisms led him to
divide the visible spectrum into five
colors red yellow green blue and violet
he later added orange and indigo simply
because he wanted the number of colors
to align with the ancient Greek belief
in the power of the number seven seven
notes in a musical scale seven known
planets seven days in a week for
centuries later you have a telephone in
your pocket that displays over sixteen
point seven million colors with clearly
defined hex codes so I know that the
specific blues for vsauce2 are 3-3 99 FF
and 0 0 6 6 C C and now blue a color
with no name for most of existence is
the most popular color in the world we
invented the color of our planet and
it's changed how we see life
Norwegian painter Edouard Munk an a
perceptual phenomenon known as
synesthesia which causes sensory and
cognitive signals to cross and it led
him to see emotions as colors he said in
my art I attempt to explain life and its
meaning to myself and while The Scream
remains his most legendary work monks
painting starry night represents how
human perception colors our reality
having just lost his first love monk
painted the view from his hotel room in
Oslo tapping into his synesthesia to
express this once-in-a-lifetime feeling
the entire landscape is bathed in the
color of a bruised heart the color of
transcendence beyond the ordinary the
color blue describing the painting he
said a landscape will alter according to
the mood of the person who sees it but
the invention of blue didn't just alter
the landscape it allowed us to advance
from simply observing our surroundings
to finally seeing our world which means
the question why is the sky blue
actually has two answers the first is at
the shorter smaller blue light waves
from the Sun scatter when they hit
molecules in our atmosphere the second
is
[Music]
we found blue and as always thanks for
watching
you
hey if you want to learn more about
yourself then click here to watch my
previous video scapegoats for this video
I want to thank Joshua Trevor something
kid McGrath Victoria and Virginia all
for their help now the new Curiosity box
just arrived this is the new t-shirt but
what I really want to talk about is this
say hello to Nikola Tesla the first in
our brand new pin series curious
creatures which is a mash-up of some of
the most curious humans of all time with
some of the awesomest creatures of all
time on the back you get to see a brief
biography of Nikola Tesla and this is
the first of many to come so if starting
now each curiosity box will include
another curious creature so if you
subscribe now you get to start your
collection from number one as always a
portion of the proceeds from the
curiosity box goes to Alzheimer's
research so thanks for supporting all of
our brains thanks for supporting your
brain and thanks for supporting Vsauce